بعد الغواصات ها هي استراليا تتخلى هذه
المره عن مروحيات فرنسيه وتستبدلها بلاك
هوك الامريكيه وفي التفاصيل كشفت وزاره
الدفاع الاستراليه انه سيتم استبدال
مروحيات فرنسيه من نوع باخرى امريكيه من
نوع بلاك هوك الامريكيه على الرغم من
الجهود الحثيثه التي بذلتها باريس في
اللحظات الاخيره لانقاذ الاتفاق الحكومه
الاستراليه قالت انها معذوره ولديها
الاسباب الكافيه وهي ان نفقات صيانه
المروحيات الفرنسيه مكلفه جدا ولم تحصل
على ساعات الطيران التي تحتاج اليها من
هذه المروحيات
والثقه اذا بين البلدين كانت قد تراجعت
عام 2021 عندما الغت استراليا بشكل مفاجئ
صفقه بقيمه اثنين وستين مليار دولار
امريكي مع فرنسا طبعا انا ذاك لش غواصات
[موسيقى]